bien mes chers collègues madame la
ministre nous examinons aujourd'hui la
proposition de loi relative à la
restitution des restes humains
appartenant au collections publiques
déposées le 26 avril dernier sur le
bureau du Sénat par 3 de nos collègues
en l'occurrence Catherine Morin de
saillie Max Brisson et Pierre ouzouillas
lors de sa réunion du 9 mai dernier la
Conférence des Présidents a accepté que
ce texte soit examiné selon la
préposition dure de législation en
commission prévue au chapitre 14 bis du
Règlement du Sénat je vous rappelle
qu'en vertu de cette procédure le droit
d'amendement des sénateurs et du
gouvernement sur le texte concerné ne
peut s'exercer qu'en commission la
séance publique programmée mardi 13 juin
prochain sera par conséquent réservé aux
explications de vote et au vote du texte
que nous allons élaborer au cours de la
présente réunion
je vous rappelle que celle-ci est
ouverte à l'ensemble des sénateurs mais
que seuls les membres de la commission
de la culture présent dans la salle sont
autorisés à prendre par au vote cette
réunion fait par ailleurs l'objet madame
la ministre d'une captation
audiovisuelle diffusée en direct et en
vidéo à la demande sur le site internet
du Sénat je
vais donner sans plus tarder la parole à
notre rapporteur Catherine Morin de
saillie pour qu'elle nous présente son
rapport sur ce texte
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
mais très cher collègue
depuis l'adoption de la restitution de
la Vénus dans toutes il y a maintenant
plus de 20 ans le Sénat notre Assemblée
a toujours joué un rôle moteur en
matière de restitution de restes humains
dissensible
je veux rendre du coup hommage Nicolas
Abou ancien collègue sénateur et
Philippe Richardt qui était rapporteur
aussi de la loi musée de 2002
qui comme moi avec la loi sur les têtes
maori se sont fortement engagés pour que
cet enjeu soit mieux pris en compte par
notre pays mieux compris
je veux aussi remercier tout
particulièrement mes collègues Max
Brisson et Pierre ouzulia coauteur de
cette proposition de loi avec lequel
nous avons poursuivi ces dernières
années un grand travail de fond au sein
de notre Commission en matière de
restitution de bien culturelle et je
veux aussi remercier notre président
pour son soutien constant sur ce dossier
qui nous mobilise tous j'ai également
une pensée pour me permettrait pour
Claire chastaner ici présente qui est
adjointe au sous-directeur des
collections
musées de France qui a été aussi par sa
présence constante notamment au sein de
la commission nationale scientifique de
collection un élément de référence pour
pour nous
alors c'est un sujet vous l'aurez
compris qu'il nécessite beaucoup de
ténacité j'en veux pour preuve l'échec
de notre tentative l'an passé avec la
proposition de loi relative et la
circulation et retour des biens
culturels extra-européens dont
l'assemble nationale n'a malheureusement
jamais inscrit l'examen à son ordre du
jour j'espère donc que le texte que nous
examinons aujourd'hui
nous avons eu le temps d'approfondir du
coup le sujet connaîtra un sort plus
heureux car je suis convaincue que notre
pays a besoin d'affirmer une position
claire et de se doter d'un cas Pirène
pour répondre en toute transparence aux
demandes de restitution et je sais à cet
égard madame la ministre que vous êtes
sensible cette nécessité dès votre prise
de fonction vous avez manifesté votre
intérêt pour la question et je vous
remercie avec mes collègues du soutien
que vous nous avez apporté jusqu'à
présent
les collections de restes humains sont
des collections particulières parce
qu'il s'agit de corps humain ou
d'éléments de corps humain il nécessite
un traitement respectueux digne et
descend même si une par minoritaire des
collections est d'origine étrangères et
parmi elles seulement une minorité
d'origine extra-européenne la question
de leur restitution peut se poser compte
tenu des principes de respect de la
dignité de la personne humaine et de
respect des cultures et croyances des
autres peuples
bien que l'essentiel des restes humains
provient de fouilles archéologiques on
compte aussi dans les collections des
établissements publics culturels et des
universités des pièces collectées dans
des conditions inacceptables en
particulier pendant la période coloniale
je pense au trophée de guerre des vols
des pillages des profs
comme pour les biens culturels spolier
aux familles juives pendant la période
nazie le principe d'inaliénabilité fait
obstacle aujourd'hui à leur restitution
le les chateur est le seul compétent
pour y déroger c'est l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles très peu de restitution
de restes humains sont intervenus
jusqu'ici on ne compte que deux
restitutions par voie législatives
toutes deux effectuer au cours de ces 20
dernières années la Vénus est en top les
têtes Maury la lourdeur et la complexité
de la procédure législative on conduit
du coup à privilégier à plusieurs
reprises d'autres voies de restitution
malgré leur licéité discutable nous
étions tous émus de la restitution de
crânes à l'Algérie en 2020 par le biais
d'une convention de dépôts de 5 ans
crâne désormais inhumé dans un cimetière
d'Alger mais juridiquement toujours
propriété de la France
l'utilisation de ces stratégies de
contournement et révélatrice à mes yeux
du besoin urgent à définir un cas
juridique qui permet de simplifier la
restitution des restes humains la
situation actuelle n'est évidemment pas
satisfaisante pour les états demandeurs
je pense à l'Australie avec lesquels un
travail scientifique conjoint sur les
collections vient juste de débuter mon
collègue Pierre ouzoudia nous les avons
rencontrés alors que leur demande
remonte à 2009 et je me suis souviens
très précisément à l'époque de leur
démarche
l'Argentine et Madagascar ont également
transmis des demandes bien que plus
récentes j'ai pu constater aussi combien
ces obstacles juridiques sont également
devenus une source de difficultés pour
les établissements concernant ces pièces
soumises à une pression croissante pour
justifier de leur présence dans les
collections
les mentalités on considérablement
évolué je dois le dire depuis l'affaire
de la tête maori de Rouen en 2007
l'adoption d'une dérogation de portée
générale au principe d'inhabilité ne
fait plus peur je crois pouvoir dire
qu'elle est même attendu
il faut dire que le travail amorcé au
sein de la commission scientifique
nationale des collections à la demande
du législateur suite à la loi sur les
têtes maori poursuivi ensuite par le
groupe de travail présidé par Michel
vanpraet pour lequel j'ai également une
pensée que nous avons reçu il y a 3 ans
a permis de faire avancer la réflexion
et d'identifier un certain nombre de
critères de restituabilité qui font
consensus la présence proposition de loi
s'en inspire très largement et je note
que dans son rapport monsieur Martinez
souligne l'excellent travail de ce
groupe de ce groupe sur les restes
humains
alors que prévoit exactement cette
proposition de loi
elle met en place une procédure
administrative permettant à l'état et
aux collectivités territoriales de faire
sortir de leur domaine public par décret
en Conseil d'État des restes humains
identifiés comme étant issus du
territoire d'un État étranger dans les
buts de les lui restituer le texte
définit strictement les conditions dans
lesquelles cette procédure peut être
utilisée elle concerne exclusivement des
restes humains tout d'abord dans
l'ancienneté est inférieure à 500 ans
deuxièmement qui appartiennent à un
groupe vivant dans la culture et les
traditions restent actives
troisièmement dans les conditions de
collecte portent atteinte au principe de
la dignité humaine ou dont la présence
dans les collections est incompatible
avec sa culture et ses traditions enfin
et dont la demande de restitution est
portée par un État étranger
elle n'est d'ailleurs pas possible à des
fins d'ailleurs possible qu'à des fins
funéraires par le mot funéraire il faut
entendre pas forcément une inhumation
mais un traitement de respect et dommage
du mort cette condition n'empêche
cependant pas la constitution d'un
mémorial du coup dans l'état d'origine
l'objectif est qu'il puisse être rendu
donc cet hommage aux morts dans le
respect des croyances et culture de ceci
afin d'éviter que les restes humains il
ne correspondrait pas à la demande de
l'état d'origine lui soit restitué un
comité scientifique composé à part égal
de représentants français et de
représentants de l'État demandeur
devrait être chargé de vérifier leur
identification en cas de doute afin de
permettre bien sûr au Parlement de
contrer l'action du gouvernement mes
chers collègues une fois qu'il y aura
délégué son pouvoir d'autoriser la
sortie des collections notre texte
prévoit qu'il soit destinataire chaque
année d'un rapport relatif à
l'application de cette procédure
j'ai le sentiment que ce disposition
répondent aux préoccupations exprimées
depuis plusieurs années pas notre
commission elles mettent en place un
cadre clair et transparent les critères
prévus par la proposition de loi
similaire à ceux qui figuraient dans le
texte que nous avions adopté en janvier
en janvier 2022 sont suffisamment précis
et objectifs pour justifier la
dérogation au principe d'inhabilité
consensus par le législateur la
procédure ménage par ailleurs une
véritable place à l'expertise
scientifique permettant de se prémunir
contre des restitutions qui seraient le
fait du prince je vous proposerai
néanmoins dans quelques instants un
amendement pour sécuriser davantage
encore la prise en compte du travail
d'instruction scientifique
son adoption me paraît nécessaire pour
faciliter à l'avenir les restitutions de
reste humain au regard de l'augmentation
très probable du nombre de demandes à
très brève échéance ce dispositif nous
permettra de régulariser la restitution
des crânes algériens avant l'expiration
du délai de 5 ans prévu par la
Convention de dépôt
je souhaite également attirer votre
attention sur son intérêt diplomatique
j'ai l'espoir que les comités
scientifiques nous avons espoir pour
tout dire que les comités scientifiques
mis en place conjointement avec l'État
demandeur constituent les prémices de
coopération culturelle et scientifiques
à venir ils sont en tout cas un bon
moyen de commencer à écrire en commun le
récit d'une histoire passée mieux
comprise et mieux appréhender enfin sur
le plan interne il me semble s'agir d'un
outil important pour inciter nos
établissements publics à adopter une
démarche plus proactive et engager un
travail en profondeur d'identification
et de documentation des restes sensibles
qu'ils conservent dans leur collection
reconnaissant en effet que
l'inalliabilité n'est pas l'unique
obstacle au restitution le fait que
l'immense majorité des restes humains
soient anonymes leur origine vague ou
encore inconnue constitue il faut bien
le dire une réelle difficulté
je crois pourtant que la documentation
des restes humains conservés dans les
collections fait partie intégrante du
respect de la dignité de la personne
humaine associée à ses restes aussi
madame la ministre j'en appelle à vous
afin de donner aux établissements les
moyens humains et financiers suffisant
pour approfondir le travail de recherche
sur leur collection qui est si
nécessaire cette proposition de loi en
effet n'est finalement qu'un amorceur
avec elle le législateur fait sa part en
levant les obstacles juridiques qui
pèsent sur les restitutions de restes
humains autour du gouvernement
d'apporter ensuite son plein soutien à
la recherche scientifique pour mettre à
jour les provenances les origines les
identités
j'ajoute pour finir que cette
proposition de loi ne sera sans doute
qu'une première étape législative sur la
voie des restitutions de restes humains
apportent appartenant aux collections
publiques
il n'apporte en effet une solution
pérenne aux États étrangers laissant de
côté pour leur le sujet des restitutions
de restes humains d'origine française la
restitution en 2014 du crâne du chef à
taille à la Nouvelle-Calédonie illustre
pourtant bien l'existence d'une
problématique
ultramarine particulière qui s'explique
par les liens étroits entre ces
territoires et notre passé colonial la
Commission avait déjà
identifié cet enjeu lors de l'examen de
la proposition de loi relative à la
circulation autour des biens culturels
extra-européens et avez-vous voulu alors
autoriser les groupes humains à pouvoir
demander la restitution des restes
humains d'origine française
la question des eaux humains mis en
lumière ces derniers temps rend
nécessaire de faciliter la restitution
des restes humains ultramarins j'ai
ainsi été saisi du cas de reste humain
d'Amérindiens Kalina conservée au Musée
de l'Homme qui correspondent à des
individus décédés à Paris alors qu'ils
étaient exhibés dans de tels
manifestations ethnographiques leur
restitution est sollicité à juste titre
par leur descendants en Guyane qui ne
sont qui se sont constitués en
association je les ai très longuement
additionnés il serait légitime qu'il
puisse retourner sur leur terre
d'origine à des fins funéraires je vous
proposerai donc dans quelques instants
un amendement pour que nous puissions
prendre date afin d'avancer rapidement
sur cette question qui préoccupe
également et je les salue nos collègues
ultramarins en attendant de trouver une
solution pérenne à cette problématique
pierre aux zoulia avec lequel j'ai
beaucoup travaillé ma lycée il y a
quelques jours à l'oreille l'idée de
déposer dans les établissements
culturels des territoires concernés
certains restent humains ultra marins
conservés dans les établissements
métropolitains je vous livre là madame
la ministre cette piste provisoire et
nous comptons sur vous pour avancer bien
entendu sur ce dossier extrêmement
sensible mes chers collègues je vous
remercie de votre attention
de la parole à madame la ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur
mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs et un grand merci pour cette
proposition de loi qui est pas du tout
une loi technique et une loi qui touche
à notre histoire ou plus profonde notre
humanité à notre rapport à la mort à la
fraternité
c'est une loi assez philosophique au
fond
par le passé des restes humains sont
entrés dans nos collections publiques
après avoir été
acquis de manière illégitime voire
violente que l'intention ait été à
l'époque de recueillir des trophées ou
de constituer des collections dont on
croyait qu'elle disait quelque chose des
différences entre les hommes le résultat
est le même par ses actes l'humanité a
été blessée des peuples ont été lésés
aujourd'hui nous souhaitons
collectivement avancer sur le chemin des
restitutions et votre proposition de loi
cadre nous permet de le faire comme vous
l'avez dit les restes humains ne peuvent
pas pour l'instant être restitués dans
le cadre de la loi en raison de
l'inaliénabilité des collections
publiques
hérité de
l'ineliabilité du domaine royal et
réaffirmé par la République cette
inaliénabilité des collections c'est un
principe protecteur c'est important de
le rappeler qui a garanti la
transmission du patrimoine de la nation
jusqu'à nos jours dans l'intérêt de tous
pour le partage avec le plus grand
nombre donc chacun en connaît la valeur
nul ne souhaite aujourd'hui le remettre
en cause mais là nous parlons de restes
humains un terme voilà on n'a pas trouvé
mieux mais
techniquement ce sont des restes humains
et quand ses rêves sont arrivés dans des
conditions suspectes que leur
conservation dans un musée heurte les
principes de la dignité humaine nous
devons pouvoir interroger la légitimité
de leur présence dans les collections
publiques et pouvoir conduire avec
méthode avec raison avec rigueur
scientifique dans le dialogue la
sérénité un processus de restitution
sans pour autant renier le principe
général d'inaliénabilité
je voulais ici prendre
un exemple de reste humain mal acquis
qui fait l'objet d'une demande de
restitution le squelette du fils du chef
amérindien Liam Pichu fait une demande
faite par la communauté ma bouche était
par l'Argentine avec qui nous
travaillons sur ce dossier depuis
plusieurs années vous le savez tous
ça sépulture semble avoir été pillée par
l'équipage du conte Henri Delaveau qui
entre 1896 et 1897 a parcouru la
Patagonie en s'installant auprès des
populations locales indiennes et en
prélevant au cours de cette exposition
ce qu'il appelait lui-même un butin je
vous fais grâce du récit de l'eczumation
du dépeçage du corps et de la cuisine
macabre quand rideau Lavaux décrit
compte les amants dans son voyage en
Patagonie paru en 1901 mais bon un seul
passage quand même que je vous cite de
bon matin il dit lui-même de lui-même un
moment je me fais horreur
j'ai pour moi une excuse que diable car
je rapporterai en France un beau
spécimen de la race indienne qu'importe
après tout que ce thé ou lécher dorme en
Patagonie dans un trou ou au Muséum sous
une vitrine
parmi les 29 caisses et les 1371 kg du
fond Lavaux voilà au moins un objet dont
il
n'est pas véritablement un objet
d'ailleurs un reste dont il nous importe
aujourd'hui que des experts français et
argentins examinent la légitimité de sa
présence dans les collections du Muséum
national d'histoire naturelle
nous ne pouvons pas réparer les actions
du passé mais il est de notre devoir de
créer les conditions d'un dialogue
serein au présent cette loi si elle est
votée permettra par le consensus l'étude
historique et scientifique d'extraire
des collections des restes humains qui
n'auraient pas dû y entrer et aux
communautés d'origine d'honorer la
mémoire de l'un d'entre eux dans le
respect de leur rythme funéraire
on pourrait également parler des restes
humains des
aborigènes d'Australie depuis plus d'un
siècle Céreste provenant d'Australie
principalement des crânes sont conservés
dans plusieurs institutions muséales
françaises notamment au Muséum national
d'histoire naturelle et au Conservatoire
d'anatomie de la Faculté de Montpellier
c'est collections de crânes humains à
travers lesquels on a cru pouvoir
classer les individus ce sont développés
dès la fin du XVIIIe siècle avec l'essor
de la crâniologie de la phrénologie ces
sciences approximatives qui ont servi
les théories raciales les plus sombres
dès les débuts de la colonisation de
l'Océanie au 18e siècle s'écra n'ont
fait l'objet d'un commerce ignoble
interdit en 1831 par le gouvernement
britannique en Nouvelle-Zélande et en
Australie mais qui s'est malheureusement
poursuivi illégalement bien au-delà de
cette date
en 2014 au terme d'un long et fructueux
dialogue entre la France et l'Australie
il a été décidé de mandater des experts
chargés de recenser d'éventuelles restes
humains aborigènes figurant dans les
collections de musées français en vue de
leur rapatriement
et tout récemment je veux saluer la mise
en place du comité conjoint
franco-australien le 16 mai dernier qui
en s'appuyant sur les recherches
d'identification et d'authentification
de restes humains conduites depuis donc
cette époque 2014 va permettre de
conclure un accord et relance activement
la perspective d'une restitution qui
grâce à cette loi pourra avoir lieu
prochainement
jusqu'ici seul de loi d'exception ont
permis d'aller au bout d'une démarche de
restitution vous l'avez dit pour des
restes humains avec l'Afrique du Sud et
la Nouvelle-Zélande grâce à votre
implication et votre détermination
madame la sénatrice Catherine Morin de
saillie le Sénat vous l'avez souligné je
le redis c'est montrer dans ces deux cas
à l'avant-garde des préoccupations
légitimes de notre époque et à
l'initiative de ces deux textes qui ont
commencé leur parcours législatif si ces
deux lois d'espèces ont permis de tenir
dans nos assemblées des débats de
qualité et de faire émerger ces sujets
dans l'opinion publique elle ne concerne
que des cas particuliers et non pas
permis de fixer des principes généraux
c'est ce que vous nous permettez de
faire aujourd'hui et c'est dans cet
esprit qu'à mon arrivée au ministère de
la Culture j'ai voulu engager un
dialogue avec le Parlement autour de
l'adoption de trois lois cadres sur les
restitutions
et que nous avons entamé ensemble un
travail concerté
je n'y reviens pas vous vous en avez
parlé
je me réjouis que la première de ces
lois relatives à la réception des biens
culturels ayant fait l'objet de
spoliation dans le contexte des
persécutions antisémites perpétrées
entre 1933 et 1945 a fait l'objet d'un
vote unanime au Sénat le 23 mai dernier
et là je me réjouis que le Sénat soit à
nouveau en première ligne avec l'examen
de cette proposition de Loire relative à
la réception des restes humains et je
veux vraiment saluer le travail que vous
avez fait madame saillie avec Max
Brisson et Pierre rozulias votre rapport
de décembre 2020 qui fera date cette
mission d'information qui a été
déterminante
contrairement à la Loi sur les
spoliations antisémites qui prend appui
sur un cadre méthodologique éprouvé et
des structures existantes comme la CIVS
la commission d'indemnisation des
victimes de spoliation nous sommes ici
plutôt en terrain vierge en réalité
c'est dire l'importance de cette loi qui
pour la première fois va fixer une
méthode et un cadre je sais que de
nombreux échanges ont eu lieu avec les
services de l'État les équipes du
ministère les professionnels du droit
des musées les instances internationales
cette proposition de loi également été
éclairée par le rapport demandé par le
Président de la République à Jean-Luc
Martinez dans les conclusions qu'il a
rendu il livre un panorama général de la
situation et une synthèse des
différentes solutions retenues par les
États vous vous êtes également appuyé
sur les dossiers en cours d'instruction
avec l'Algérie l'Australie Madagascar ou
encore l'Argentine
vos propositions réaffirment la
nécessité du dialogue bilatéral du
respect des personnes et des communautés
de la recherche scientifique je les
soutiens je les approuve et je m'engage
aussi vous avez bien fait d'insister sur
ce point à tout faire pour faciliter
encourager les recherches de provenance
et les travaux d'identification
je veux vraiment vous remercier encore
une fois madame la sénatrice Mora de
saillie messieurs les sénateurs et
Brisson pour cette proposition de loi
qui est une loi de justice et de dignité
merci beaucoup
si madame la ministre je vais ouvrir
maintenant le la discussion générale en
commençant par un des co-auteurs de la
loi pierre
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
la Ministre merci Madame la rapporteur
cher Catherine moi j'aimerais commencer
par vous rendre hommage madame la
sénatrice parce que c'est dix ans de
travail disant d'amnégation 10 ans à
essayer d'imposer une question
fondamentale que l'institution muséale
ne voulait pas voir
et à traiter pendant très longtemps par
par le déni et il fallait tout votre
force de persuasion pour arriver
aujourd'hui à un texte comme vous l'avez
dit madame la ministre qui a un texte
fort qui est pas un texte technique
qu'un texte qu'on peut le dire avec une
certaine inspiration philosophique je
crois pas que les sénateurs fassent de
la philosophie je pense pas non plus que
il est à réparer l'histoire mais quand
nous pouvons faire avancer le droit pour
prendre en compte des idées
philosophiques qui aujourd'hui
plus communément par partager je pense
que on réussit à faire notre travail
alors dans votre odyssée madame la
sénatrice je vous ai accompagné sur les
derniers moments les plus favorables le
retour à Ithaque j'ai pas vécu l'épisode
ni des sirènes ni des lotophage
les sirènes ne touchaient pas aux
collections publiques et l'autophages
calmez-vous tout se passe très bien il y
a pas de il y a pas de problème donc je
suis très content avec vous de voir
l'approche des rivages d'Ithaque et ce
texte faire un cheminement qui qui
conduira est adopté sans sans difficulté
ce que vous défendez ce que nous
défendons par par le biais de ce texte
c'est une certaine idée de
l'universalisme
nous pensons collectivement que
[Musique]
le traitement de nos morts fait partie
d'un universel qui est partagé par nos
sociétés humaines depuis très très
longtemps et aujourd'hui il y a une
petite polémique archéologique pour
savoir si finalement on pourrait pas
considérer que le traitement premier
traitement donné aux morts serait
beaucoup plus ancien que ce qu'on
pensait aujourd'hui ça touche à la
dignité de la personne humaine dont nous
considérons qu'elle se prolonge au-delà
de au-delà de la mort et ça ça touche
aussi au respect que nous devons au
peuple dans la façon dont ils endommage
à leur mort sans jamais juger de ce qui
pourrait être bien comme traitement
funéraire ou pas et je trouve que la
formule qui a été trouvée et très juste
parce qu'après tout si les oraux astria
de l'Inde dans les tours du silence
souhaite exposer leur mort au bec des
vautours c'est en fonction d'une vision
du monde que nous partageons peut-être
pas
mais qui est parfaitement respectable
digne et elle aussi en cri ancrée dans
un discours philosophique d'une grande
importance donc je crois que c'était
important alors que nous défendons le
musée français comme un universel de
prendre en compte la valeur universelle
de la dignité rendue aux morts on
pouvait pas considérer que au nom de
l'universalisme des musées on pouvait
s'opposer à ce besoin universel de
rendre hommage aux morts il y avait
quelque chose qui était incongru et que
nous allons essayer de réparer avec avec
ce texte
j'insiste avec Madame la rapporteur il
est vraiment important de lancer
maintenant un immense travail de
récollement des collections
parce qu'on sent bien que
le travail n'a pas été réellement fait
et madame la ministre je pense que ça
serait l'occasion d'une très bonne
collaboration avec les universités avec
les étudiants pour faire que les musées
puissent demander à des étudiants dans
le cadre de travaux universitaires de
les aider à faire ce récollement des
collections à déterminer les les
origines de ce squelette il y a là une
possibilité de mobiliser les étudiants
les universités dans quelque chose qui
pourrait être un peu plus partagée que
le seul récollement technique réalisé au
sein d'un
musée
Catherine Morin de saillie l'a dit nous
avons essayé de prendre en compte le
problème de ces restes humains qui ne
viennent pas de la métropole mais qui
viennent de territoires qui aujourd'hui
appartiennent encore à la République
française le la législatives et fort
complexe et nous avons abandonné par par
manque de temps mais je crois qu'il faut
aussi faire droit et la modeste
proposition que j'ai fait c'est à dire
l'organisation d'un déménagement sur
place dans un cadre qui resterait celui
d'une collection publique permettrait
provisoirement au moins de satisfaire
certaines
demandes
je finirai
en redevenant un petit peu archéologues
ce que je suis de moins en moins
vous vous avez au sein du ministère de
la Culture ensuite un travail important
à faire sur les restes humains
500 ans c'est peu et les travaux de
l'INRAP notamment sur des sépultures sur
des restes de moins de 500 ans sont
nombreux je sais qu'aujourd'hui l'INRAP
met en oeuvre des protocoles pour donner
des traitements particuliers à ces
vestiges
osseux mais je je crois qu'il serait
bien que sous forme d'une circulaire
d'une forme administrative légère vous
poussiez donner à vos services des
instructions pour faire que l'esprit de
la loi tel que nous le défendons ici
soit aussi respecté dans le cadre de
toute de toutes ces fouilles je crois
qu'il faut être très attentif à tout ça
et que on peut pas considérer que des
vestiges humains soient simplement des
des objets archéologiques mobiliers
comme comme tous les autres voilà je
veux pas être plus long mais je vous
remercie je vous remercie encore une
fois Catherine Morin deci mais je vous
remercie aussi madame la ministre pour
la qualité du travail que nous avons eu
avec avec vous et avec votre et avec vos
services et puis aussi la profondeur de
l'ampleur de la réflexion que nous avons
pu avoir à l'occasion de de cette
proposition de loi merci monsieur le
président
Cédric Vial qui je crois s'exprime aussi
au nom de Max Brisson merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre madame la
rapporteur chers collègues c'est un défi
pour moi de prendre la parole comme ça
après Catherine et Pierre je vais le
faire au nom de Max Brisson qui est qui
avait un empêchement ce matin la verve
Brissonnière en moins
tout d'abord je voudrais évidemment
commencer par remercier Catherine Morin
de saillie pour le long très long
travail tu l'as appelé pierre sur les
restitutions des biens figurants dans
les collections et qu'elle a réalisé
depuis maintenant plusieurs années
le Sénat a construit et s'est construit
une doctrine dans dans la durée au fur
et à mesure des travaux qui ont pu être
menés
nous n'avons pas d'opposition de
principe pour restitution mais nous
souhaitons l'établissement de règles
claires pour éviter le fait du prince et
rendre nos collections publiques
otages nos parents de nos collections
publiques au tachent des viciss itudes
de notre diplomatie voilà le corps de
notre doctrine nous réaffirmons aussi
notre refus à des lois de circonstances
au cas par cas sans réflexion historique
sur les objets conduisant à des
restitutions parfois polémiques ou le
Parlement a pu être considéré comme une
chambre d'enregistrement des décisions
de l'exécutif et même parfois à
posteriori de de ces décisions ou de ces
restitutions
nous avons une volonté également pour
que toutes les restitutions soient
accompagnées d'un accompagnement
culturel et d'un échange s'inscrivant
dans dans le dialogue des cultures et
nous souhaitons l'instauration d'une
instance indiscutable
éclairant l'exécutif et le législateur
sur les objets leurs histoires et les
conditions de leur entrée dans les
conditions dans les collections
publiques ces positions ont encore été
affirmées dans le rapport de nos trois
corps-à-porteurs désormais associés sur
sur toutes ces questions Catherine Morin
de saillie pierre ouzulias et Max
Brisson elles l'ont été jusqu'à l'an
dernier elles ont pardon jusqu'à l'an
dernier suscité une attitude pour le
moins distante de la part du
gouvernement
voire ressenti parfois comme du mépris
sous le ministère de votre prédécesseur
Madame Bachelot et cela donc pu créer
une certaine tension avec avec le Sénat
nous avons assisté
après votre arrivée madame la ministre a
un précieux revirement de position
pourrait-on dire voilà voilà un an avec
une proposition que vous avez faite au
Sénat de
d'une nouvelle position qu'on pourrait
qui pourrait s'exprimer ce selon la
forme d'un triptyque c'est à dire un
premier texte concernant le
la situation des biens culturels Juifs
spolié durant la période nazie nous
avons voté ce projet de loi voilà
maintenant quelques quelques semaines
rapportées par notre collègue Béatrice
Gosselin et voter à l'unanimité par le
Sénat vous l'avez rappelé madame la
ministre aujourd'hui nous sommes dans la
deuxième étape de ce triptyque avec ce
deuxième texte concernant les restes
humains le texte de ce matin fait
consensus on ne peut conserver des
restes humains dans nos collections et
la restitution s'impose donc
le texte de cette PPL
rapporté et portée par Catherine Morin
de saillie pierre ouzulias et Max
Brisson fixent les règles de ces
restitutions nous les approuvons donc
évidemment il reste donc à un troisième
texte à élaborer il s'agit d'une loi
cadre qui fixerait les règles de pour
l'ensemble de l'ensemble des
restitutions et vous connaissez madame
la ministre les attentes du Sénat elles
sont doubles tout d'abord le souhait
d'un éclairage scientifique indiscutable
sur les objets pressentis et enfin une
méthode claire qui autorise et qui
encadre le Sénat est particulièrement
notre commission et tout à fait prêt à y
travailler à y travailler avec vous avec
votre votre administration et évidemment
nous voterons cette proposition de loi
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur
le Président la ministre
[Musique]
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour
fixer le cadre général applicable la
restitution des résumes détenus par les
collections publiques je tiens tout
d'abord à saluer l'excellent travail de
la rapporteur notre collègue Catherine
Morin de saillie en particulier lors des
différentes auditions menées dans le
cadre de l'élaboration de ce rapport
ainsi que Pierre ouzoullias qui vient
d'intervenir correcteur et Monsieur Max
Brisson cette proposition de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui refait une
importance capitale qu'elle vise avant
tout à préserver la dignité humaine en
permettant le déclassement des restes
humains de moins de 500 ans présent dans
les collections publiques elle répond à
une préoccupation fondamentale de
respect et de considération envers les
personnes dans les restes sont issus
lorsque les conditions de collecte ou de
conservation pourrait poser question il
est primordial de pouvoir les restituer
à l'état étranger d'origine qui en fait
la demande pour garantir rigueur et
l'impartialité de ce processus la
proposition de loi prévoit de la
consultation d'un comité scientifique
composé de représentants des deux états
impliqués ainsi que des institutions
détentrices des restes concernés cette
approche collaborative et
pluridisciplinaire permettra d'évaluer
avec précision les demandes de sortie du
domaine public et de restitution en
prenant en compte à la fois les aspects
humains éthiques et scientifiques
de plus cette PPL propose de mettre en
place un dispositif cadre dans le code
du patrimoine cette démarche globale et
cohérente vise à éviter de légiférer de
manière répétitive au cas par cas en
établissant un cadre général nous
pourrons gérer efficacement les futurs
cas de déclassement et de restitution
des règles humaines dans le respect de
la dignité de chacun à notre-dame-temps
cette proposition de loi tout comme le
projet de loi relatif à la restitution
du bien culturel spolié durant la
persécution antisémite entre 1933 et
1945 on en a parlé tout à l'heure nous
comblerons une lacune juridique majeure
il ne nous restera plus qu'à mettre en
place une loi cadre sur la restitution
des biens malakis des tenues dans les
collections françaises enfin les
propositions que les propositions que va
nous faire madame la rapporteur a juste
titre il sera apporté des précisions sur
l'exécution du futur texte et sur les
possibilités d'étendre ces disposition
au territoire d'outre-mer après un délai
d'études et de faisabilité nécessaire en
soutenant cette proposition de loi et
les amendements nous affirmons notre
engagement en faveur du respect de la
dignité humaine de la coopération
internationale et de la justice dans la
gestion des biens historiques et
culturels nous avons la responsabilité
de mettre en place des mesures
législatives appropriées afin de
garantir un traitement équitable et
éthique des restes humains détenus par
ses collections publiques vous l'aurez
donc sûrement compris
notre groupe soutient pleinement ce
projet de loi et votera sans difficulté
bien entendu je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président je vais
m'associer au mot de reconnaissance du
travail constant de Madame la rapporteur
et aussi féliciter pour le travail les
co-auteurs du texte mais vous l'avez dit
Madame Lamy c'est une loi de justice une
loi de progrès une loi de dignité que
que nous allons évidemment voter c'est
un sujet qui mobilise à la fois notre
commission et le Sénat de façon assez
constante et parfois en première ligne
ça a été dit et nous partageons le
besoin d'un cadre clair et transparent
pour les restitutions et ce texte est
une première étape salutaire le respect
de la dignité de des personnes et au
cœur de la démarche et nous avons besoin
de progresser urgemment pour simplifier
les restitutions de restes humains et la
définition stricte du texte permet
d'offrir un cadre sécurisant et
scientifique pour ces restitutions à des
fins funéraires quel que soit leur forme
et le principe
d'inabilité ne fait plus obstacle au
respect de la dignité
humaine on nous propose ici une solution
donc humaine efficace transparente et
respectueuse à la fois des états
demandeurs et des principes de nos
collections et donc nous voterons pour
ce texte en espérant qu'il ne soit
qu'une première étape pour élargir le
cadre de ces restitutions je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le Président moi aussi je
voudrais saluer le travail
l'abnégation mais c'est intéressant de
Catherine Morin de saillie qui prouve
aussi que le travail n'est pas fait dans
la précipitation mais dans la continuité
et
est important pour
pour pouvoir justement faire émerger
après des textes qui qui ont quand même
déporté importante parce qu'on
s'aperçoit bien que ce texte on peut
dans tous les sens c'est quand même une
discussion de l'indianabilité
des biens qui qui ne doit pas être
totalitaire mais une réflexion qui doit
être prise en compte justement en
intégrant l'universalisme justement de
certains biens dont il faut intégrer et
analyser l'origine le parcours
et ensuite même la résidence
actuelle et c'est l'ensemble de ces
données qui doit être réinterroger
régulièrement je pense d'ailleurs c'est
l'occasion de dire qu'on a un travail de
recherche de provenance qui doit être
plus développé et d'intégrer dans dans
notre propre culture dans notre propre
pays je crois que c'est
c'était pas une discipline comme
l'archéologie avec des minant
spécialistes qui qui a été peut-être
assez
prise en compte ou en tout cas
développer nos territoires
l'autre
notre dimension de ce texte et celui du
respect de la dignité humaine
qui donc nous fait je l'ai dit réfléchir
sur
déjà le fait que un bien culturel n'est
pas un bien commun et que
[Musique]
des restes humains ne sont pas non plus
des biens culturels comme les autres
c'est une évolution de de nos
consciences qui est importante
d'ailleurs de voir comment on peut avoir
cette réflexion sur des restes humains
qui vont bien au-delà par exemple de la
fin de vie sur lesquels aussi on a en
permanence à
se réinterroger justement pour une juste
prise en compte dans nos textes
législatifs donc pour toutes ces raisons
bien vous comprendrez bien que nous
soutenons et félicitons tous les gens
qui ont travaillé sur sur ces
propositions
Pierre-Antoine Lévy
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre madame rapporteur cher
Catherine je voulais mon tour vous
féliciter pour votre ténacité et pour la
présentation de de ce texte féliciter
également notre Indiana Jones du Sénat
pierre ouzulias et Max Brisson qui est
absent mais qui a bien collaboré
également à ce texte alors aujourd'hui
c'est un sujet de grande importance dans
la continuité du texte Cédric l'a dit
sur la restitution des biens spoliés
pendant la période nazis il s'agit de la
question des restes humains conservés
dans nos établissements publics tels que
les musées les monuments historiques les
centres de conservation et d'études
archéologiques ainsi que des universités
ces collections dites sensibles
nécessitent une attention particulière
le respect du corps humain ne cesse pas
avec la mort comme le stipule notre Code
civil
la constitution de la restitue la
question de la restitution de ces restes
à leur pays d'origine se pose la cacuité
et bien que la majorité des restes
humains conservés dans les collections
soient d'origine française il existe des
milliers de pièces collectés à
l'étranger certains cas peuvent être
litigieux on l'a vu et susciter des
demandes de restitution de la part de
pays tiers il peut s'agir soit de
persuader
soit d'un individu anonyme dont
l'appartenance à un groupe est établie
ou de les conditions de collecte sont
connues cependant la restitution des
restes humains conservées dans les
collections publiques est actuellement
complexes en raison du principe nous
l'avons rappelé d'inalienne habilités du
domaine public les restes humains font
partie du domaine public et sont sous la
responsabilité des entités publiques qui
ne sont pas autorisées à les CD d'aucune
manière que ce soit volontairement ou
sous contrainte à titre onéreux ou
gratuit ainsi leur sortie du domaine
public nécessite une intervention du
législateur cette proposition vise
aujourd'hui à ce principe à déroger à ce
principe d'inalien habilité elle
autorise la sortie définitive des restes
humains du domaine public en vue de leur
restitution FX un cadre clair et
transparent pour traiter les demandes de
restitution de pays de restitution
émanant de pays tiers
cette démarche permettra de faciliter
les procédures de restitution en évitant
les délais inhérents à la procédure
parlementaire qui peuvent décourager les
initiatives l'article unique de cette
proposition de loi définie donc la
procédure et les conditions dans
lesquelles il reste humain pourront
sortir des collections publiques
alors cette cette proposition de la loi
est une étape importante dans la
réconciliation avec les pays et les
peuples on l'a dit également
vous savez qu'il y avait un débat au
Parlement francophone bruxellois sur la
restitution des biens culturels
africains et sa présidente Julie de
grotte fixé et des enjeux de ce débat en
les résumant en trois mots dignité
respect et mémoires collective il est de
notre devoir en tant que représentant du
peuple de VIH qui c'est le principe sont
respectés vous l'avez compris le groupe
Union centriste beautorat plus que
favorablement cette proposition et vous
félicite cher Catherine encore une fois
pour la qualité du travail
merci permettez-moi aussi de dire un mot
d'abord pour se féliciter de la qualité
du travail fait sur sur ce sujet ou
combien délicat je voudrais également
saluer personnellement l'implication
depuis de nombreuses années de notre
rapporteur sur sujet et la persévérance
donc elle a fait preuve et
l'accompagnement des deux autres auteurs
de cette proposition de loi et pour
avoir participé à quelques réunions je
sais que c'est un travail aussi
interactif qui a permis d'aboutir à
cette rédaction salut aussi bien sûr
madame la ministre puisque quand il y a
quelques mois vous nous avons discuté de
la façon dont vous vouliez
travailler sur cette question du des
restitutions au sens général vous avez
proposé que le texte de sur les restes
humains viennent du Sénat et évidemment
nous sommes très sensibles à cette
proposition j'ai
une question à vous poser néanmoins
puisque j'ai lu comme beaucoup avec
attention le rapport de Monsieur
Martinez même s'il n'a pas jugé bon de
nous auditionner et d'auditionner les
sénateurs qui ont travaillé sur ce sujet
néanmoins j'ai lu le rapport et sur la
partie sur les restes humains il précise
que le décret d'application enfin une
prepsis il propose que le décret
d'application de la loi cab précise que
les frais d'analyse et de rapatriement
soient à la charge du pays demandeurs
vous nous rassuriez sur cet aspect un
peu mesquin peut-être de la demande de
de du rapport Martinez pour faire en
sorte que ça ne soit pas une règle
intangible mais peut-être l'objet de
discussion entre les pays
oui merci monsieur le Président ce
rapport est un d'une proposition sur la
table à débattre évidemment ensemble et
et bien évidemment il y a d'autres
options que celle-ci ça peut être un
partage moitié-moitié ça peut être dans
certains cas la France qui paye enfin je
pense qu'il faudra être plus souple
effectivement dans la rédaction
merci votre réponse madame la ministre
on va examiner les amendements sans plus
tarder
ah oui pardon il y a la définition du
périmètre type de l'article 45 madame la
rapporteur qu'est-ce que vous proposez
comme périmètre
alors je vous propose mes chers
collègues que le périmètre pour
l'application de l'article 45 de la
Constitution comprennent les
dispositions ayant très à l'organisation
à la procédure et conditions applicable
en matière de restitution de restes
humains appartenant aux collections
publiques à contrario je vous propose
d'exclure de ce périmètre les
dispositions relatives au cadre
applicables aux restitution d'autres
types de bien culturels relevant de ce
collection mais je pense que l'objet de
la proposition de loi était extrêmement
clair à cet égard
il y a pas d'opposition à la définition
du périmètre il est donc ainsi adopté
nous allons placer maintenant l'analyse
des amendements sur l'article unique il
y a deux amendements un premier
amendement comme un de notre collègue
madame finira horte je ne crois pas
qu'elle soit dans la salle Médicis je
les ai madame le rapporteur de donner
son avis merci monsieur le Président
donc c'est un amendement qui vise à
étendre la procédure de restitution
prévue par la présente loi aux demandes
formulées par les populations outre-mer
comme j'ai tenu à l'indiquer assez
longuement dans mon intervention
liminaire l'objectif de cet amendement
est légitime mais il y a une vraie
problématique
ultramarine à ne pas sous-estimer je me
suis moi aussi avec Pierre rosoya on a
eu beaucoup de discussions jusqu'à ces
derniers jours beaucoup interrogés sur
l'opportunité de déposer un amendement à
ce sujet il nous semble arriver à la
conclusion que la procédure prévue par
ce texte n'était pas en état
transposable aux outre-mer comment en
effet étendre une procédure
interétatique ainsi conçu de manière à
favoriser les coopérations culturelles
et scientifiques à des territoires
français qui relèvent d'une
problématique finalement nationale
et d'ailleurs des directeurs de musique
nous avons auditionné se poser la même
question
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
contrainte de les mettre à la vie
défavorable à cet amendement non pas
encore une fois sur le bien fondé de de
la demande mais sur la proposition
technique somme toute pour y aboutir je
serai souligné aussi que
cet amendement soulève de véritables
difficultés juridiques puisqu'elle met
sur un pied d'égalité des États
étrangers et des populations qui en
elle-même ne constitue pas une entité
juridique nous en conviendrez donc
s'agissant du cas mentionné par Madame
Pinera Horse j'ai moi-même entendu comme
je vous l'ai dit les représentants de
cette association appelée molico à
l'aide pot qui sollicie de la
restitution de leurs ancêtres disparus
ce sont des ancêtres directs pour
la personne concernée j'étais vous en
douter extrêmement sensible à leur
démarche c'est pour ça que je vous
proposerai dans un instant que nous
engageons à trouver une solution rapide
pour résoudre cette problématique
ultramarine
si l'adoption de ce nouveau cas devrait
prendre d'ailleurs trop de temps il nous
resterait toujours la possibilité d'une
loi d'espèces pour faire sortir les
restes humains en question conservées
dans les collections du Musée de l'Homme
mais avant on peut pouvoir l'envisager
je pense qu'il faut aussi bien entendu
et je sais que le travail est aussi
engagé
s'assurer que l'ensemble des restes
humains conservés dans ce musée ont été
bien identifiés
voilà donc ce que je voulais vous
soumettre comme avis à l'amendement
avis défavorable même s'il est pris en
compte à travers l'amendement qui va
suivre des préoccupations de notre
collègue qui suit le pardon pierre
merci monsieur le Président je partage
complètement la vie de la rapporteur il
faut il faut quand même rappeler
monsieur van praete la bien montré que
l'essentiel des restes humains conservés
dans les conjonctions publiques viennent
de France métropolitaine même pas ultra
marine à une époque comme vous l'avez
dit ou on essayait de d'identifier sur
des crânes des ossements ce que pouvait
être des races propres à la France il y
a des crânes de Bretons d'auvergnat sans
doute de Corréziens
je pense que on pourrait pas faire droit
aux collectivités d'outre-mer de
demander la restitution c'est bien et
l'interdire à d'autres communautés
métropolitaines qui le souhaiteraient
donc il y a tout un travail qui est à
faire et notamment on pourrait réfléchir
à des formes administratives en
considérant que peut-être que au moment
où les pièces ont été données pardon par
l'aigle aux collections il y a par
rapport à la législation actuelle une
forme une forme de vis qu'on pourrait
casser pour permettre une une meilleure
restitution c'est une piste que je que
je vous donne mais mais là encore une
fois je crois qu'il est essentiel que le
récollement de toutes ces collections
nous donnent quelques statistiques sur
la masse de ces de ces restes humains
merci monsieur le président
demander la vie du gouvernement sur
l'amendement même avis que la rapporteur
vous avez pesé chaque mot et tout était
très précis et à la fois respectueux de
cette préoccupation très légitime
en effet on doit prendre ce temps le
travail est déjà engagé y compris en
interministériel pour trouver le
la cohérence et l'équilibre parce que
d'une part on ne peut pas là on est dans
le cadre d'un texte qui va traiter des
demandes d'état à état donc ça ne peut
pas fonctionner pour
des demandes nationales et d'autre part
on ne peut pas créer des situations où
il y a une rupture d'égalité au sein de
la République entre les territoires
d'outre-mer et des autres donc on a un
chemin à trouver et on s'y attelle même
avis en tout cas
donc deux avis défavorables sur cet
amendement je vais le mettre au vote qui
est défavorable à l'amendement
est-ce qu'il y a des avis favorables des
abstentions il n'est pas adopté nous
passons aux comme deux de notre
rapporteur alors c'est un amendement qui
vise à sécuriser davantage instructions
scientifique des demandes de restitution
il a pour but d'empêcher que la sortie
de reste humain des collections puissent
être décidées avant que le comité
scientifique mixte n'est formellement
rendu son rapport au gouvernement madame
la ministre et à l'état demandeur
contrairement finalement ce qui s'est
produit pour les crâne algérien en
voyant en Algérie avant que le comité le
comité mixte mis en place n'est remis
son rapport définitif et n'est même
finalisé son analyse concernant
l'ensemble des crânes qui lui étaient
soumis l'amendement demande donc que le
rapport du ministre de la Culture qui
doit servir de guide à la décision de
sortie des collections soit établie sur
la base des conclusions du rapport du
comité mixte lequel lorsque un tel
comité mis en place ce qui garantit la
Remise Formelle au préalable
vous demandez l'avis du Gouvernement
madame la ministre a dit favorable bien
sûr c'est d'ailleurs le cas de figure
dans lequel nous sommes avec l'Australie
je l'ai indiqué tout à l'heure avec ce
comité mixte donc tout à fait d'accord
il y a pas d'intervention je vais le
mettre au vote qui est favorable à
l'amendement proposé par le rapporteur
est-ce qu'il y a des avis défavorables
non pas d'abstention donc adopter nous
passons au dernier amendement ah non il
faut un vote sur le l'article unique
ainsi modifier qui est favorable à cet
article
c'est uneanimité merci
il y a un moment important article
additionnel après l'article unique je
donne de nouveau la parole à notre
rapporteur pour nous présenter
l'amendement comme 3
c'est un amendement que j'ai déjà
finalement évoqué en filigrane dans mon
intervention liminaire et en traitant
l'amendement notre collègue Pinera North
donc cet amendement numéro 1
c'est une proposition que dans un délai
d'un an à compter de la promulgation de
cette loi le gouvernement remette au
Parlement rapport qui va identifier les
solutions possibles pour mettre en place
une procédure pérenne de restitution des
restes humains d'origine du territoire
des collections régies par les articles
73 et 74 et de la Constitution et de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie conservée dans les
collections publiques voilà c'est en
fait somme tout un travail que nous
demandons au gouvernement de faire
digigence pour trouver une solution à la
problématique
ultramarine
telle est la vie du gouvernement madame
la ministre avis favorable totalement
favorable
sur cet amendement je le mets au voie
qui est pour l'adoption de cet
amendement
uneanimité je vous remercie l'amendement
comme 3 et donc adopté devient article
additionnel
nous allons passer au vote de la
proposition de loi ainsi modifier s'il
n'y a pas d'explication de vote je vais
la mettre aux voix qui est pour son
adoption
ce qui a des votes contre des
abstentions elle est donc adoptée à
l'unanimité dans la rédaction
issue des travaux de la commission
notre réunion de législation en
commission s'achève je remercie
la parole à notre rapport oui je
voudrais juste dire un petit mot pour
remercier notre président d'avoir
soutenu de manière constante le travail
que nous avons effectué avec mes deux
autres collègues vous remercier bien
entendu madame la ministre d'avoir été
attentive à ce sujet et je crois qu'on
aboutit aujourd'hui à une étape tout à
fait essentielle dont nous pouvons être
collectivement fiers parce que
finalement tout ça c'est du collectif
c'est du partage d'une préoccupation qui
nous est chère et je crois que la France
peut-être regarder avec fierté
aujourd'hui à l'Unesco je sais où les
débats vont bon train ça sera très
important je pense la façon dont sera
reçu enfin je terminerai en remerciant
très chaleureusement
Aurore Bassi à ma droite notre
administratrice qui fait un travail
exceptionnel sur ce dossier depuis
plusieurs mois plusieurs années même je
dirais sans nous administrateurs de la
commission nous ne pourrions finalement
produire ce travail de grande qualité je
vous remercie
je crois que vous voulez dire à moi
aussi vous remercier de nouveau chers
Catherine Morin de saillie parce que je
sais que ça a été un travail de longue
haleine qui arrive là un magnifique
aboutissement et je m'engage à ce que ce
soit inscrit le plus rapidement possible
à l'Assemblée c'est important pour
clôturer en beauté ce cheminement
législatif encore merci
merci
je remercie chacun d'entre vous pour sa
participation nous nous retrouverons
donc pardi prochain dans l'hémicycle
pour les explications de vote et le vote
définitif sur ce texte merci